hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 5 video learned so
much about Caitlyn snows character we
learned what happens when you eat her
pizza pockets
fair warning she gets really upset so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet here we go so much
Star Wars in this episode it was really
like an episode about people turning to
the dark side of the force
you know like fear leads to the dark
side fear leads to Catelyn lashing out
like the little kid is lashing out
because he feels powerless and wants to
feel powerful Catelyn is afraid so she
lashes out but every time she does that
her physiology becomes more killer frost
and it's not reversible so it's like
once you go to the dark side you don't
come back so let's do top 10 WTF and
Easter eggs as we go on there's a whole
bunch of stuff in this episode in a lot
of backstory we learned a whole bunch
about Kaitlyn in a whole bunch about
Julian Albert so number 10 Barry and
Cisco are living together now Cisco
doesn't seem like he's super down with
it but it's just because Barry needs
another place to live and it just gives
the show an opportunity to do new types
of scenes with these characters in
different places like sometimes it's
just fun to see them chilling out away
from work but Barry's awkwardness is
kind of a nice hat tip for number 9 new
Wells is super creepy way overdoing it
with the new team just like reads up on
all of them learns about their coffee
but somehow misses the fact that even
though Wally's name is Walter he doesn't
go by Walter it was until like halfway
through the episode till it's stopping
sinister and just started being silly
but number 8 we finally get to meet
Caitlin's mother so there was so much
exposition about Caitlin's backstory
before she came to STAR Labs in all
these scenes so we learned that
Caitlin's father died after a long
illness her mother who's been like this
brilliant scientist for a long time
tried to help him but couldn't do it
so as a way to cope with it just
completely disengaged emotionally from
her family it basically tore their
family apart so Caitlin rather than stay
under her mother's shadow decided to
break away to make a name for herself
just like number 7 WTF you know Julianne
Albert so he learned a lot about
Julianne Albert in this episode he comes
from a wealthy family but was kind of
the
odd man out so left to make a name for
himself and had about four years of
military training so number seven big
monster stomping around downtown but
something doesn't seem quite right it
looks enormous it is like a kaiju sized
monster that looks like a cross between
a white Martian in parallax so you know
part of the problem with this really
like the thing that should tip you off
as to why this might not actually be
real is because the National Guard
hadn't been called there wasn't a
national emergency there'd be a lot more
chatter happening if there was an actual
monster on earth they just appeared out
of nowhere
but number six Kaitlyn's mother starts
testing her powers if you haven't read
the comics a lot of the versions of
killer frost there are a couple
different versions of the character most
of them got their powers in a lab
accident so just like waiting for
something crazy to happen but they just
continue to tease the tension between
the two of them like things are just
slowly building Kaitlyn is getting ready
to lose her you know on top of all
that we also learnt like Kaitlyn's
mother like it sounds like they haven't
been talking recently because she
doesn't know about Rani like it seems
like she doesn't know anything about
what's happened to Kaitlyn the last
couple years you're at that STAR Labs
place with that man you followed by
number 5 Barry
Empire Strikes Back moment there's a
whole bunch of Star Wars like there was
you know thematically a lot of Star Wars
stuff and you know fear leads to anger
anger leads to hate hate leads to the
dark side type stuff with like Caitlin
going to the dark side slowly because
she's giving in to her fear but then
there D also has the line I always
wanted to be a Jedi so there was a lot
of like literal Star Wars stuff
happening in a lot of metaphorical Star
Wars stuff happening but of course
number four the monster is a hologram so
it wasn't a metahuman it was just a kid
I couldn't find his name but I don't
think it's anybody from the comics it
was just somebody who was making noise
to feel powerful he was kind of like a
throw away villain for the episode so
I'm not expecting him to come back it's
kind of the same thing that's happening
with Wally's storyline but that's mostly
going to be dealt with in next week's
episode so I'll talk about that at the
end of this but number four they find
out what's going on with new wells he's
not a scientist he's a complete fraud
he's just writing a novel as a way to
try and get back into everyone's good
graces back on his or because everyone
there found out what was going on so he
used this is an opportunity to write a
really good story to make everybody like
him again so they say they're going to
give him a couple weeks to prove himself
meaning that I think he'll be gone by
the midseason finale because of course
Jessie quick in earth - Harrison wells
will come back so I think that'll be
like the transition from new wells back
to Jessie quick earth to Harrison wells
so I just I feel like he's not going to
be around for a little bit longer and he
is kind of an annoying character it's
fun to see a different version of Wells
but I do feel like more than a couple
weeks of him would be just like a little
too much we're number three we learned
that Julianne Albert really does not
like the new metas because they're
misusing their abilities he wants to be
special to which meet you know I feel
like there's a big twist coming with his
character like what if you were special
but you didn't know it because of
multiple personalities so there are a
number of different ways to explain how
Julianne Albert here can be Albert
Desmond from the comics it have a
different persona that is dr. alchemy so
they have a couple different ways they
explain it in the comics and a lot of it
has to do with the alchemists stone but
it seems like what they're doing here is
trying to make Julian Albert a really
sympathetic character that you like that
you want to save in at the same time
have tom felton play the doctor alchemy
persona so I think what they're trying
to tease here is that there's going to
be like a big choice team flash will
have to make with dr. alchemy and Julian
Alpert like how do we save Julian Albert
but also get rid of dr. alchemy if
they're linked so just open up a tab in
chrome for that we still have a lot to
learn about dr. alchemy like they've
only been teasing him so far so next
week he'll be back we'll get a whole
bunch more scenes with him via Wally's
storyline number two this was a lot of
fun Caitlin totally almost kills that
lab tech that tried to trap her now in
all fairness she was trying to defend
herself but she totally looked like she
was ready to kill him before her mother
walked in they got really heavy-handed
with the language - you're not a killer
like they're just teasing killer frost
big time in number one of course was
like that post-credit scene where she's
like Caitlin don't use your powers every
time you use them your body changes a
little
bit more and we won't be able to reverse
it so she has this emotional outburst
uses her powers again but then realizes
holy
so the teaser here is that like little
by little she's going to be becoming
killer frost and you guys let me know in
the comments how close to like
full-blown killer frost do you think
she'll get before the team finds out now
episode 7 is titled killer frost so it
sounds like something really big is
going to be happening with her storyline
in that episode maybe she'll go
full-blown killer frost or maybe it'll
be like a slightly different looking
version of the character that'll require
a little bit less makeup but also still
look very much like comic book killer
frost I think they're gonna find a nice
balance like they want to do a new
version of killer frost with danielle
panabaker so whatever ends up happening
it's gonna be a lot of fun but expect
more outbursts like this where she just
like slowly turns into killer frost just
a little bit more in a little bit more
until she can't hide it anymore but like
I said next week is going to be a big
Wally dr. alchemy episode you know
they've been teasing that that might be
how Wally gets his powers like he goes
to dr. alchemy and starts hearing voices
in his head straight observations though
like one of the most fun little bits of
information about Caitlin we learned in
this episode is that she eats like a
total college kid she leaves that little
tag for Cisco don't eat my pizza pocket
Cisco so she has a stash of pizza
pockets somewhere inside STAR Labs but
the other weird thing too was like the
big metahuman war that earth 19 Harrison
wells told them about and then the
thought that their entire coffee crop
had been wiped out like he made it sound
like coffee did not exist on his earth
anymore but let me know like what was
your favorite thing from this episode
you know besides just seeing Caitlin
just completely lose her so why you
guys think about that I will say new
round of the giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I'll
do a trailer video tomorrow morning and
just because so many people have
requested it I'll do an arrow episode
video for human target tomorrow night
too so just a heads up about that so a
whole bunch more comic book stuff
happening this week well you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
learn what's going on with the flash
movie why the director quit and you can
click here for my non-spoilery Doctor
Strange review
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight